moi j'aime bien portants à dire eh bien
oui allez-y non non parce que là c'est
pour être sérieux deux minutes en plus
vous avez qu'aujourd'hui est décédée et
un jeune garçon qui était arrivé
tellement vrai tout navire mais film
entièrement refaits vous l'aviez rudy
molard et 50 minéraux change et éthique
mois pour avoir traîné avec beaucoup
beaucoup de gamins à l'époque d'nrj12
c'est un peu comme une drogue ce truc
cette dernière qu'ils adorent ils font
un truc puis un autre virage comme c'est
à toi lui non mais c'est vrai et ça j'ai
vu mais c'est un genre où je te promets
que la plupart des gens de télé réalité
a vu le faisais plein de chirurgie pour
faire un truc à machin et 125 ans est
sûre je vais vous donner un exemple tout
simple au départ je vous le jure que
c'est vrai les bogdanov est allé chez le
coiffeur
[Applaudissements]
pour finir en une seconde que je veux
juste te dire c'est que c'est du prime
elle est là elle est rigolote elle est
charmante karine le marchand on oublie
qu'on devait malgré tout et s'excuser
mais quel rapport
ces nations j'aimerais avoir quelques
ambitions source médicale s'est passé